And some of you may be wondering whether
you're actually in a relationship with a
psychopath or whether the youth,
you might've fallen for a psychopath in
the past.
And if you are in a relationship with a
psychopath,
a what you can do about that.
Now,
uh,
psychopaths do have certain
characteristics.
Certain tells a,
to use a poker analogy,
a that they display in relationships.
Um,
they tend to play on our pity a lot.
Okay?
So they tend to excuse they're
misdemeanors and bad behaviors,
um,
through something that would be on their
control.
They couldn't help doing it because you
know,
something had happened and you know,
there's always an excuse for it.
And all those psychopaths don't feel
emotions like us.
They are masters at pushing those
emotional hot buttons that elicit
emotions in,
in,
in others,
in us.
Uh,
sympathy being one of the major,
major motivators.
Okay.
A psychopath also tend to be very
narcissistic.
Um,
they tend to think that the world
centers around them.
They're not really attuned to your
feelings.
They don't really care about your
Uh,
really,
ultimately the world,
uh,
surrounds a,
surrounds them a solid psychopathic,
also very charming.
They're very manipulative,
especially when they're in a crowd,
especially when they're in company.
Uh,
but behind the scenes when they're alone
with you,
they can be very,
very controlling sometimes,
but not always aggressive,
but psychologically controlling as well.
Okay.
So if you're worried about the fact,
if you're worried that your,
uh,
you know,
in,
in a relationship with a psychopath,
what can you do about that?
What might be some certain things to,
to look out for?
Well,
first of all,
the absolute first thing to do is,
uh,
to not go on face value,
to not fall for the smokescreen.
Okay?
Uh,
number one rule of thumb is to don't
judge a person on what they say,
but judge a person on what they do.
Okay?
So that's the very first thing.
Look at the evidence of their behavior
and try to judge it objectively rather
than subjectively.
Not An easy thing to do.
I admit.
If you're in a relationship with
someone.
Secondly,
if you suspect that your partner is a
psychopath,
why don't you get a second opinion from
one of your friends?
Why don't you confide in your friends?
I think my partner is a psychopath or I
think these,
are there certain characteristics?
Give me an honest opinion.
What do you really think about my
partner?
Okay.
And a second opinion.
Two heads are often better than one in
this kind of case.
Thirdly,
numb.
A golden rule is don't cover for them if
they start getting into serious trouble
and they want you to somehow front up
for them or be an alibi or somehow make
excuses or whatever,
whatever.
Don't get tangled up into covering up
for them because as soon as that starts
happening,
it's called the foot in the door
technique.
A very,
very common persuasive technique.
Once you've done something for someone,
you're more likely to do other followup
things for them.
And before you know it,
your in,
up to your neck.
Okay.
And the fourth thing I would say is buy
my book,
uh,
because all the,
all the signs and all the tricks of the
trainer in there.
Uh,
and fore warned is definitely forearm
when you're dealing with sign up.